greetings welcome to the Church of
what's happened now and the church is
brought to you by on it for all your
supplement needs go to Hannah comm from
hyper brain - shrimp export to shrimp
take a meal
these things are tremendous I love the
hemp cord protein shake the chocolate
listen alpha brain you don't like it you
send it back here the money person
hundred-percent money-back guarantee we
don't even want the product that's how
much balls we stand behind it go - honey
calm / character and get 10% off right
now this podcast is also brought to you
by me undies me and these are the
softest most comfortable underwear your
ever wears period and summer is the
perfect time to upgrade your under gray
underwear draw so do me a favor go to me
on these calm right now I'm gonna give
you 20% off your first pair plus plus
plus free shipping at me undies comm
slash Joey and I tell you what I got
some new bold designs and bright colors
increase the peace your dig and the oak
the underwear the meat on the underwear
underwear the OG go to me undies calm /
Joey right now kick that meal lid
what's happening you bad [ __ ]
uncle Joey here with my main Jewish
savage Lisa at and Ari Shaffir is on the
phone
we had a great podcast together and we
had a great response from you people I
had no idea that this was such a topic
you know I really appreciate Lea talking
about it tonight because well all that
since she talked about having slept I
just been thinking about this and
reading up on depression so what I did
was I spoke to Lee and with double check
with Lee if it was okay
and we can have a Harvey called then who
dealt with this you know when he dealt
with this for a while and explained his
uh his challenges what will you think
buddy I'm excited I'm excited too uh
it's been an amazing couple days and I
can't wait at uh I'm excited that I'm
excited to take help from people for so
long I've been just trying to do
everything myself so it's not too
help listen nobody ever thinks they need
help we all feel like we got it covered
until one day you actually go foul you
know for a year we'll [ __ ] keep doing
the same damn diet right
I didn't eat cheese and I until one day
you know you know what I gained a pound
I'm all the way watch it oh I'm having
the surgery I'm doing it you know it
always takes the end of a rope before
you ask for help you know so insights
it's naturally its natural and on top of
that mental health issues have such well
not a stigmata the last couple years
it's been more accepted people
understand it more it's not like when I
was growing up baby you were [ __ ]
crazy or you weren't if you went to
something instead I had suicidal
thoughts they punch in the face ten
times and they'd send you home you know
I nobody really understood those things
50 years ago 20 years ago I to listen to
different people speaking over the years
I could tell that I have a dab of
something I don't know what it is but
who the [ __ ] cares
get re on the phone let's get this body
starting yo okay can you get me now
yeah perfect I wish you look good
what were you saying kid I said perfect
perfect what'd you have for lunch today
nothing I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] I had chili
yesterday for some diner on the Upper
East Side I can't stop [ __ ] shooting
what you have comics Oh sucks ass and
chili why the [ __ ] would you have chili
on the Lower East Side those [ __ ]
savages don't know how to make chili
then white beep every time I let go man
operate excited stylish as Feinstein is
up there oh but Spanish people don't
make [ __ ] chili ari that's a white
thing you gotta find a people with
cowboy hats and that each other cheese
and wrong you know that's how you make
like ostrich and it was terrible
yeah [ __ ] that [ __ ] I don't trust a
chilly out here very seldom I just went
somewhere where they had nice chili with
the red [ __ ] kidney beans you go back
to your hotel room you fought up a storm
in there you got to open up the window
to window don't want to open anyway are
we a [ __ ] little Jewish friend here
the other day we're having a podcast
and we're just talking about different
states of mind and he was talking about
at the time you know he seems like he
has depression you know and he shocked
the [ __ ] out of me because he's got the
girlfriend the job the car
he's got the Boston Red Sox geometry you
know him to be depressed I don't know
what he's got to be depressed about but
I started thinking more and more about
it and it related to your situation when
you first told me that you were feeling
kind of weird and you got to take
medication I was in shock because you're
the most happiest go lucky guy I've ever
met
what is the intro feelings to depression
I mean what do you feel at first it's
like a just like everything's a little
worse never get like you know the stick
those bit doesn't commercials they do it
for like that burden the new TVs let me
show the old TV next to the new TV yeah
and it will be able to be the picture
just like you can tell what it is it's
just like another look spying is going
to be like oh wow that's why that's HD
it's library so it's like if life is an
HD and then you go back to my old TV
it's just like everything's a little
worse the Red Sox win a game instead of
going yes you go alright that's cool
take and then the negatives are just in
your mind they just get bigger starts
that way and then it gets worse and
worse to the point where it's almost
like debilitating you can't do anything
to do everything sucks that's the point
where it was like you know might be a
beautiful day out in February might be
75 degrees in February and it's like oh
I love this weather you know it's sunny
it's great but then it's my car it's
like I gotta get gas I'm gas like those
[ __ ] sucks
hey can gas I should have just being
like a little nothing disruption of your
day comes like a major thing
your mind it's just like if it's like a
sprain in your mind you just can't can't
fix it either do with like come as Nomar
did it's ain't depression like you're
depressed it's like should we call
something else it had the same symptoms
of just like you know when your teen
losers you feel down or to think
something left it a stage then it goes
away and like after a while you know one
or two days being depressed normal
depressed that that's fine you can deal
with that clinical depression ur just
never goes away even if the thing gets
solved you know maybe your sibling or
mom dies and you get depressed and then
like you get over that the depression
stays or if you lose your job that's a
good one it's a lot of time major thing
can control you into it so see you
losing job and then you know you go into
a depression and then you find a better
job I'm better
you know like higher paying and
something you like doing more the
depression stays I don't know what it is
so it's not about the job job is just
what got you hurt in the first place
that stays that's what starts getting
real bad do you feel sad re I never
really feel I don't know I feel down but
it's not like I want to cry I don't feel
sad it's just uh it's I don't know it's
not it's a weird it's more just like I
like for me it's more about I don't feel
like I'm good enough like that like that
almost of it's just negative stuff about
myself like if like I'll start thinking
about like something that I that I
started doing is I would sing I would
realize like I'd get into the day and
I'd start thinking how long it had been
since I had like a bad thought not like
a bad like I'm gonna go kill myself but
like some days you'd wake up and like
the first thought in your head is just
like shitty and then other days is good
and then like an hour and you're like oh
[ __ ] that was my first bad thought and
it like it's weird like it could be just
like I guess for me it's not really
based around things I have to do it's
basically like when I what I can't when
I keep personally
can do why don't I have why don't people
like I don't think anyone likes me like
why didn't I have friends an element
like we're going back to that like for
me and I think a bait is it's really
related to how my like and I don't want
to say I had a bad childhood it's just I
was thinking about it today it's not
like bullying is a really big thing
right now
and when you think of bullying you think
of like someone pushing you
so I'm punching you and that happens but
it's almost worse when you know like I
thought I thought I just don't left out
as a kid I don't know I've always felt
and I don't know why I always wanted to
be I always wanted to just be normal
but for whatever we I don't know if I
don't know if I'm just nerdy and then
the kids didn't really who maybe maybe
it's me me like that's like that's where
I would go it's like maybe there's a
reason why they didn't like me maybe was
because of this or maybe it was I said
this and then I think about like I'll
say like today I was thinking about this
thing this kid said to me before an 8th
grade trip to an amusement park which
has no bearing on my life at all I'll
spend hours on it yeah so that's really
where mine is I don't I don't know and
that's what I know and that's why people
have been so amazing and generous and
telling me to go talk to someone because
I haven't had it diagnosed so maybe
maybe the word depression isn't the what
right word for me maybe it's more
anxiety or who knows the grenades could
be bipolar it could be like lots of it
is very anxiety there's like lots of
different things end up getting caught
in a stigma like of like um you know
exact definition or exact title for
whatever you're feeling but a lot of it
just falls in the same category is kind
of like right it's kind of like just
mental health right it's kind of like
when people say drugs
what does drugs do you and then you got
like well it can do a lot of things but
you really have time what drug you're
talking about you know what meth dose
you is way different than what we does
here right but it's all undertone to
drugs and it's all it's like mental here
that's a better word for it yes right so
when you worry about too much about like
is this depression or the anxiety is
there a polar disorder or is it just
like a bunch of other ones much familiar
with all of them the main thing is just
like your brain
is a muscle and you can spray in it
and you gotta get got to get it set to
get back how long did you go undiagnosed
re and you will feeling these emotions
I'm trying to think over a year for sure
maybe a couple I remember telling
Chandra we're talking once and I
mentioned that I had thoughts of suicide
but they just call like don't consider
doing it but I think about it yeah
that's I mean like I can really and that
not not that like I even considered
doing it or thinking about me doing it
just thinking about the idea of it that
and then also as weird as it sounds and
as happy as I am doing what I do the
thought that I could just like I've been
in a call and I feel like I could just
leave right now I have my wallet I have
my phone I could just leave and for
whatever reason those two things would
help your tiredly tight like physically
tired No uh yeah at all um not at all
like and that's and that's honestly
that's a weird part about my about the
depression is part of the thing that I
like
I'm just negative about myself so when
I'm getting depressed I was like I
wouldn't even have the balls to commit
so as like as weird as that sounds it
would even get like I'd be like I could
never do that I wouldn't have the balls
to to jump off sounds well I understand
that
I don't one thing only to Mondays one
thing that I would reason why I wanted
you to call on this because I know
nothing about this topic and I've read
about it for hours and days I've I've
read about why I do the things I do you
know how I am Mari I get high and I
think about what made me rob that purse
would make me do this would make me do
that you know and I try to find answers
for it but after listening to you two
guys for the first minute like I think I
wrote this down when I was writing the
beginning of a book like from the age of
16 to 23 maybe re 22 I didn't want to
kill myself but I didn't want to live
either
right do you Holmes I am like I didn't
want to kill myself but I just want to
be close to my mom I was just waiting
for a [ __ ] truck to hit me
I was just waiting to rob somebody then
for them to pull a gun out and shoot me
like it is so easy yeah like that it
felt like you know and over the years I
got rid of those feelings and I don't
wake up sad you know that's why I never
understood like I understood your
depression but not really you're my
brother so you know I started talking to
you about it and I know that you
wouldn't spoke to somebody and it helped
and everything changed you know and was
there a process after you spoke to
somebody well I spoke to a few people
spoke to a few people and I was already
going to therapy just to like try it and
that's why I suppose - and issues like
you should bring up those thoughts
you're having for the therapist you
think so and she look yeah 100% it was
it was okay so there's some tips they
give you more like okay so like Roca
never could understand it and talk about
a lot of people understand where it's
like if you just get up and do some
exercise you'll feel better but what
people don't understand is you can't get
up and do exercise you can go to the
fridge you can even get up to go to the
fridge the idea of going out and going
to you know putting on ghee and going
out and put on some running shoes and
going running it's so far past which
were capable of doing cuz it affects you
in a way it's just not like you're
depressed over a thing it just exists
depression all the time so like so
people who like would try to help me at
first give me tips like get some Sun you
know get out and get some direct
sunlight in your face for like everyday
15-20 minutes directly like you know in
a row I mean every day there's other
things like I'm in the shower or anytime
I got it easier in the shower just to
just to say out loud like five things
you're thankful for
you're happy about and uh this is
philosopher from Allah it's early
nineteen hundred's Frederick Nietzsche
he says there anytime you like take
something out loud actually solidifies
it a lot more in your brain so if I have
like us let's say a negative with it
what's out like whomever say just lately
I'm just like some reason knowing me if
I don't say it I can get over but then
if I say out loud
[ __ ] Pete just bothers me from then
on everything he does is gonna bother me
so you go the opposite way the positive
things you know where these they're like
like I love this girl which is kind of
loud it's like now you do no going back
if you say some positive things you're
like the sort of the same thing actually
improve your mood a friend like cap not
wasn't my cap on actually with somebody
else if you move to Los Angeles and he
hated it you know people get with my way
he hated it give what ask him like it
wasn't like that was people would ask
them like you like LA he goes no I hate
it it asked him why and you tell you the
reasons why and they did it on whatever
and then he got so sick of having itself
of the same answers same reasons why he
hid it away that he was like I'm getting
this conversation again so we just
started saying we were like you like you
like he just kind of easier to go yeah I
like it instead of having to like say
the same thing over and over again the
smog there's no change of seasons people
a shallow whatever it was and then
people will ask Michael what do you like
about our leg and then he'd say like you
know it's sunny he tried to think of
something at burritos were everywhere
you know and then after a while saying
that he found that he started to like LA
he started to focus on these positive
things just verbally only as a tactic to
avoid having dumb conversation but it
really starts with texting his movie
started actually liking a city so I'm
not saying those things will work I
think you should you should go see
somebody and talk to somebody
how did you how did you pick the person
that you want to go see because that's
people been asking me for a while and
one of my issues is that I have trouble
and then I don't know maybe there is a
reason why but I can't think of the
reason why I have trouble trusting
people
I don't like opening up right away yeah
well you gotta find some of your like
there's no uh if you don't like that
person the first person they go talk to
no harm no foul just go swish find
somebody let's go for like one or two
time how long did you get cuz I've never
been to a single session it's pretty fun
man it's pretty fun it's like having a
one-way conversation it's like having a
conversation where the person is only
interested in what you're saying
that's weird from that like see that's
that goes back to what I was saying as a
kid i got like i don't think there's
been a conversation and i hope i don't
have when when joey holds quarter when i
see comedians talking i that makes me
real uncomfortable
i'm gonna quiet person yeah i know
because a lot of actually thinking like
i was saying well a lot of it's like i'm
not interesting i'm not we had these
icebreakers in high school to do is say
i mean if somebody saying that we had a
everyone to meet somebody else and then
say something interesting about yourself
I got there late I was somewhere else I
had too late I guess they'd given the
rundown what you're supposed to do it's
like something I've seen like herself
when I got caught up the girl who's
telling me like we could say so much
today or so I said I don't really have
anything exchange by myself and she goes
wow that's what the guy said people are
gonna say look you didn't you were here
for that part we said that's what your
natural tendency is to say like mock my
stuff my life is just not that unique
and she's like she did the guy the
moderator and said that's just wrong you
could find something interesting but I
get it when you're on Joe Diaz like
after like but in you don't need that
guy she's like wait and it's weird like
I'm not obviously don't butt in but it's
it's like the I almost wish I had gone
and seen somebody before like five or
six years ago because my I mean parts of
my depression have gotten a little bit
that like just as depression grows it
gets a little bit
stronger but other parts of my
personality that were weaker the shyness
and the willingness to talk to people
that was way worse and it may be I was
almost protecting myself in a way I
don't know like maybe because I've
always been I always like staying inside
by myself
I was never really like the idea of
going out every Thursday Friday sad I I
went to like two parties a year that was
it I got without I was never that kind
of guy and maybe I really wanted to be I
felt I wanted to be but then I wouldn't
have fun when I was there and I know but
then I mean yeah I know this was even as
a kid is like I felt like I wasn't
getting invited places and that would
bum me out but then I wouldn't call
anybody
so part like the thinking about it the
last couple days has really got me
thinking how important like childhood is
I don't like it just I don't know me I
for me and I just seems like a lot of it
goes back to stuff that I've been doing
my whole life yeah I could because
something definitely a therapist can
help you get to they can get they can
guide your thoughts so it were not what
they do they just go on crystal start a
conversation and ask you questions and
stuff like that I see persons just talk
innocuous like what you do today okay
that's cool too like it's like I had a
sandwich do you like a pepper sandwiches
yeah get up earlier a lot no I'm not
really oh really when do you normally
get up and they're just like I just
started talking and then um you'll find
that you'll end up dealing with stuff
that you haven't really dealt with I
haven't really said out loud um Joey
even said something to me before the
podcast on on Monday he said something
over the phone I forget why we were
talking about it but he's like you you
don't like confrontation and I hate I
don't and I feel like that's part of I
feel like that's going to be part of the
issue because there's people in my life
right now who like that if I go to
therapy there's going to be some issues
brought up and like not not huge ones
but it's things that I've I've put aside
like you just push aside in your brain
and you keep dealing
of people because there's you're
supposed you've known them forever or
whatever the reason is and it's uh
that's a scary part too because I don't
want to because that could then I've
also and I don't like using this word
but I've become good at lying with
people like just about lying the people
like Oh or did this upset you or or was
it we're just would you give me this
make you angry or did I hurt your
feelings no no everything's and that's
and that's weird
depression isn't feeling bad but like I
have and I think part of it is I have a
very thin skin avoid and I don't know
like that's it just gets to me I don't
know what that is no I mean how long did
you stay talking to somebody until you
started seeing or feeling a little
better or the cloud started to go away
how long well honestly um the therapy
itself didn't help me get over the
depression it was news pills okay and
what I was under they give you type I
only want to get into because everyone's
mind looks a little different okay um so
what works is there's two things that
can cause depression it's a lack of
norcuron FN too much norepinephrine
lactose a lack of serotonin or too much
serotonin so the immunity pills
either like let's say that lack of
serotonin you need a pill would give you
more serotonin or get too much it's on a
different pill would like lower than
answered something going here system so
you have four different things and then
you have different pills that can work
on those so let's say it's you have a
lack of serotonin I think a common one
um there's a few different pills that
can like help regulate help push that
higher and they're not all going to work
and some of them come with side effects
aren't the best so you're going to
regulate like you got to be with a
professional that will tell you like
we're going to do this slowly and move
up in dosage and they stay with you in
terms like what are your side effects
that can range anywhere from from boner
problems to like weight gain
to uh to increase you know thoughts of
suicide
is that with the low serotonin Ari I'm
sorry to interrupt is that result to the
low serotonin the weight gain could be
loved serotonin a curricular serotonin
okay the general one is low serotonin
now when I was doing though is that what
I remember they say when when you do
coke you demolish your serotonin that's
why the crash the next morning is so
devastating on cocaine yeah yeah okay
exactly I'm doing that because it's like
if now you keep shot a bunch of
serotonin just system and now it's like
your body
I think it's not along the something
along those lines right yeah your body's
not like okay he's making plenty
immunity to make and then one that the
coke of MDMA like not producing it them
until you're not getting him yeah so
then you need to like yeah it could take
a definite the day after Molly people
get depressed really depressed right and
the morning after cocaine and when we
wake up your world is [ __ ] done you
know yeah there's not a long-term thing
so think about in terms of this the
plane basketball you tweaked your ankle
it hurts you as I can walk it off or
you're like I'm done I go to put ice on
this and then and then tomorrow you're
okay now compare that set up to the
brain so same sort of thing where you
might just get like let's say you do
coke can you get this depression and
it's okay tomorrow you'll be okay it'll
be bad today it's Mario you'll be okay
then sometimes your ankle is fully
sprained and it's not going to be okay
to the next day or the day after that
even if you walk on is not going to get
any better and it's going to heal wrong
it's kind of like that where it's like
this is the one you can just walk off so
you have to deal with it you got to go
in and deal with it so there you can
help for sure a lot of those therapist
will recommend pills
other times they'll say no unnecessary
I'll tell you what people
scared open so you would sounds like
we're scared of that it won't work
whether you get the wrong guy I know
Nick Youssef was was scared that he
become like a zombie if you con the
pills but here's the great thing you can
just go back to the way it was you don't
have to keep saying some of you hate and
if the pills that you get you know have
side effects that you don't like you can
just put that off so your therapist okay
I don't like this I want I want to go I
know I love you me off I'll tell you
what I way to do it no one's gonna force
you to stay on there
if you don't deal with stuff comes up
absolutely I have a little kind of an
odd question when you were playing I
know from just hearing you on podcast
and just telling you you used to play
poker a little bit mm-hmm was that
during your depression or when was that
hmm
no it started certifying poker before
that okay and I was just wondering cuz
I've been I've been going through a like
a six month to you know I'm not going
broke and I'll bet the rent but I
probably play a little bit more blank
Jackson I showed and I and I was
thinking maybe I'm trying to do maybe
I'm chasing the happiness when you win
yeah I don't know I just trying to I was
just a clean I mean it could be unknown
someone was I was close to it was it a
game of addiction of them and then done
that later than a depression at the same
time and then it was like a state home
all day play online poker and just like
blacked out I could just like try to
fill the void not sure if it was like
the rest you get them from from winning
kind of kind of stops that negative
feeling or what but I think that's a kid
coming that up yeah I'll I started lying
but I could you know it's a polygenic if
you don't necessarily start drinking to
cover up depression but then what you're
already drinking it does cover it up in
the short term anyway and now how long
you stand the medication before before
you abandon ship on it
are you drinking like am i drinking no I
I really I don't drink my issue is the
food that's what my issue is okay yeah
it's so terrific to see you know there's
a short-term relief from depression and
long-term it makes it worse so it's
funny you're not on that how about
tarifa reefer short-term relief
long-term no effects by the way okay
that's good I thought about that yes I
asked my doctor the guy is like really
good
not that physics side I want to get all
really sort of it let it set and then
want to face it and something I was like
hey and just seeing how I smoked a lot
of pot and he's like now the studies are
showing economics I thought it would be
because of the thought you get sometimes
you get too high you buy yourself maybe
do an edible maybe your mind might go in
the wrong place for years with the acid
you know when people have a bad trip
that's what it is they took the took the
ass in a bad state of mind
yeah and it took him somewhere that's
interesting acid as it never was sad or
but like I don't know whenever I come
here I never really had that issue and I
know acid never really gave me those
thoughts I do sometimes only we talked
about it last that just sometimes when
I'm alone they come in but they tend to
go away a little bit just because your
stones your brain kind of wanders so I
guess that helps a little bit
it can be a little bit more intense for
a second just because you're like
focusing on it but then it goes away
quicker I think what I know the well
don't party yeah nobody sits on the roof
is not an issue that okay somebody
totally on Twitter get off the reason
and I was like what the [ __ ] you don't
come out last night they had you gotta
think like it's a possibility but then
really should defer to medical science
and not like it seems like you know it
seems like there's really no basis in
reality but I'll tell you something
right so I was on him for a few years
eventually my doctor was like you know
the problem like it's kind of
CAF so like what you're covering up
might be picked now you don't really
know if you take the cast off so after a
few years we like we talked about it and
then and then it was like our list
starts slowly going off there keep you
know keep me updated keep the people in
your life updated that way if you start
like getting real Radek they can be like
hold on mana you're asking weird and
then you call your doctor okay I find
calm down mapping weird
you know as I'm lowering this it'll
probably tell you okay get back on the
regular dosage and what's but uh talking
two weeks let me ask you this I'm sure
Jan Schall I'm punch-drunk
did you consider call in the [ __ ]
back and tell them you're [ __ ] up
again definitely it's a thing you got to
deal with you're just going to stay just
don't cover it up like like like you
know my apartment when it's all [ __ ]
messy right just add layers to it then
it comes out I was a [ __ ] washing
nine inch nail two days ago and uh he
starts BAM hurt and I was like I found a
committed suicide and just never dealt
with it I started [ __ ] crying in
front of my friends
you got to deal with this stuff what it
like what did the medicine do for you
like what is how do you feel when you
when the medicine is working um you
don't you don't feel it when the
medicine is working it's like it's like
you just don't you don't it doesn't give
you a relation the why did let me get
your like elation or like funny thing
you computed just like it's just back to
where you were where you're like the
good days it does bad days are bad you
know if you know but it's not very
character gets killed off on a show that
will feel bad but it looks data for
three weeks
let's get it for one day okay and then
I'm gonna pee twins you can talk and
celebrate fully bring your team loses
you can [ __ ] you know be in misery for
a day but just for a little bit doesn't
like dancing everything if you get on
until it does that you need to get on
another
there's plenty out there what uh what's
the the motivation for getting off of it
like it just just me if something helped
me I I would go like oh I want to stay
on this it's working
mm-hmm after a while I noticed I hadn't
I hadn't like been in love for Peters
and you know it was that or not I was in
no rush
at some point of doctor was like you
could maybe pig booking-office you want
I'm like man and I don't need to yet I
want to risk it and then I started
thinking maybe I wasn't have it high
because of it so I was like it is time
to think about also just you know fifty
bucks a month less than and I was
spending or whatever it would that
wasn't an issue but like why not well I
have to take everything every morning to
get something where in the world I could
pharmacy in Canada and try to get it
just be a little easier nothing on it
not much but a little so I was like
maybe the new this time why you want a
location with any side effects
did you sell different ones
when I was on wellbutrin I couldn't come
I didn't I didn't know that was even a
side effect until was happening and then
I looked enough and I was like oh there
is a sofa so wasn't even like
psychosomatic another one you could be
expected to gain 15 percent of your body
weight so I did that um that one didn't
even really work so one back off it and
lost weight better there are side
effects you know there's kind of sex all
these and everybody hits everyone a
little differently so that's why you do
with the medical professionals like
guiding you through it so there's the
two types of errors the types of
prescribed stuff at expose to you um you
should try to top the kind of the top
speed first
and then if you don't really make
progress after a few months and then
start thinking about pills or whatever
they say follow what they say how do you
know I didn't so now they either the guy
that Rogan sent me to it's
a hunch it was anyway 180 bucks visit so
it was a little expensive and I'll take
they don't take insurance the ones that
insurance takes I'll tell you now
they're not as good okay um I mean I had
a lady tell me like wow I love to tell
you now it was just accepted like i
right I'll just look at the courage
eventually kill Michael she was bad at
her job um so your land was good at the
job and someone else are you next with
don't run for lily I want massages
coming from a lady and that's what
massages my man vice versa the one for
180 you will go on every week on me
mm-hmm which one so one for 180 you will
go on every week now not every way um it
was less than that I did it to wait 30
every week to start and then I'm going
to be too late for every month he wasn't
looking to shake me down it wasn't like
that he was he was like an honest part
of car repair place where they're like
hey just so you know this is a major six
not yet to probably next ten thousand
mile this guy was kind of like that but
he was just like you can start from
unless you know who started with him
better and then he would like by the
engines like come one more time six
months now let's just check in again so
he's not living to shake it off the
money he's got honey acquire you can he
write a check he's very good uh do you
still keep in touch with him in turn the
time dollars if I had a problem I would
call him immediately you do not have a
do you have like somebody to talk to now
or any medicine you take every title if
something bad happens or are you just
totally off everything I'm not that well
you know um so yeah if something bad
happens it could take a day or two I'm
like whatever but after a couple days in
looking at it and go let me see the
stage put them concert get a problem to
come you get this weird thing where you
start like feeling like your depression
is part of your family
you don't want to go away it is part of
who you are
it's not that I don't want it to go away
part of it part of it is scary because
who knows maybe I'm using it as an
excuse now for certain things like girl
like maybe because I'd like to lose when
you were talking about like oh you can't
go out
I wouldn't feel like oh I can't go out
and do this but I like I would just find
myself for like three or four hours
after I'd get up just like not just not
wanting to get out of bed like I'd get
on my phone for a second I turn over and
try to sleep but then I couldn't sleep
and I could just close up Mel clamp that
phone is a problem yeah I don't like to
preach on it too much it comes up and I
like to preach but I play it it's same
study is it that there's a bit of stuff
that it does it makes you unable to
sleep staring at the screen physically
makes you unable to sleep you take
something away from your eyeballs I'm
sort of coding that you don't know and I
just look at a couple minutes
you can't just all right back asleep it
makes you stay awake
kind of like when you play video games
for 30 straight hours there are those
screams that's up to you and you're
right next to it but also it fills you
with like desire to be connected it with
staying
yeah it's considered like knocking on
that phone while you're in bed okay I'll
put you outside
that could work make yourself get
outside then check it and it's hard for
me because I've always I'm a tech guy I
was never a sports guy so all this stuff
is stuff that I've always found comfort
in movies TV computers when I came out I
always in here I always enjoyed them so
I guess maybe it's a safety but I I feel
like that's what we've been talking
about it like Joe and Isis like safety
and then he even mentioned it on mondays
just idle hands never really and so like
that's why I'm excited about talking to
someone so that maybe I could get in
that I like that idea maybe keep the
phone because Joe you do that too right
you keep the phone out of your bedroom
you dip it in the okay for the bedroom I
don't take it into the gym I do not do a
lot of things at that phone I give my
mind a break on purpose gotta you know I
see these things on Twitter five ways to
get less addicted to your phone listen I
don't do [ __ ] on this [ __ ] phone
it really doesn't mean nothin to me I
got Twitter and hotmail those are most
important things to me on this phone I
don't I don't know how to do anything
I don't know how to do anything when the
lift guy picks me up he does it for me I
call him on the personal side and he
picks me up made those the numbers in
there for me I don't work yeah I don't
look [ __ ] up on my computer
you know I don't Google [ __ ] none of
that nothing I'll even how to do it I
didn't wanna do it like if you aspirated
Chinese restaurant I would not [ __ ]
do it I don't like my phone as much as
most people I have it just because I
like I have a new thing in there too
right but besides that I don't you know
Howie I watched you know you do kind of
a 360 but I never you know when you were
starting to get the depression I was on
the road where you were Rogen we were at
yeah we were and I wouldn't see it you
know the erratic behavior I just thought
you were [ __ ] crazy so Who am I to
judge it so when you took this trip to
this last year wherever the [ __ ] you
went and where you were drug-free and
just riding on yourself that's why you
would probably have it I'm putting all
these pieces together right now Ari like
I'm putting well yeah I mean if things
that go into making me feel negative you
know a lot of that is is that fun a lot
of its responsibility having to be
places I mean I was pretty happy I got
that because I was free from any
responsibility plus the fun and fun but
like nobody counted on me for anything
should gets annoying yeah I think breaks
I'm not - but isn't like when I when I
when you went on that trip I was I was
jealous I was very like that's something
that I would always that seems very cool
to me that seems very fun but like when
I'm I go yeah I would be fun to not have
any responsibilities I'm like oh like
then I get negative about like just have
thought like maybe I like watching
everyone else works every day like why
like why do I need this break like why
like I don't know I could just you kill
I don't know you but that I think I
think everybody needs a break you think
everyone needs a drink everybody
to break you're absolutely right yeah
yeah
where America has left vacation time
than any other country in the world
I was listening Ari to your podcast I
think was two weeks ago with the
traveler and you were talking about the
leap year and that's a lie I got judge
judge I remember this feeling when I was
graduating high school like I just
wanted to I've always wanted to be an
adult you know and just be working and
but I never really had it it was just
like the idea of being an adult so I I
left school early I left I worked I took
summer classes so I could graduate a
semester early and just start working
and listening to what you guys were
saying makes me like I wonder maybe if I
should have just taken and I liked I
thought I liked what I was doing and
editing and stuff like that but maybe I
should have taken a year off and maybe I
would have found I should have been a
chef and Frank I don't know like it's
just it's a weird well probably 29 yeah
yeah I don't think there's like I'm
supposed to be anything but there is
that point in your life and it's right
around that or it's like am i doing the
right thing I don't think the lead year
comes to like help you find what you're
supposed to be in life I think there is
nothing they're supposed to do you to do
but I think it just gives you relief
like the summer breaks used to get in
high school in college they were great
if there were two months off and you can
go back and you're talking about your
life refreshed and afterwards you don't
get that [ __ ] anymore and it's just like
just build and build and build see like
I mean the [ __ ] break I need a break
you got to see somebody man you're going
to see a therapist I'm not bad that
they're pretty fun you'll start to like
it pretty steep oddly won't like your
first guy no matter who it is just
because like just because it's like your
first one but you can just start it do
you have insurance to know oh yeah I
have insurance and I have excited some
people reached out and we're going to
add we're going to look into my plan and
and see what I had available so I'm
definitely gonna do it I mean do you
look if you have any recommendations for
things to look for or things to ask when
you're looking for a therapist no I mean
I always thought I need to look I got a
woman at first my friend Pete was like
he could only open up to women his
trouble open up to men and the next when
I got a man I looked on others actually
easier for me I fell to him
but I didn't know that going in it's
kind of like and then I might not be it
might not be gender-based you might need
someone younger somebody older and also
your friends and cells aren't like the
same thing you know ideas it's [ __ ]
75 and and uh you know somebody knows
okay we left no I found the same listen
you're preaching to the choir I tell
them all the time just to go to
jiu-jitsu because he could talk to kids
for the 29 and 28 he spends his time
with me and Steve Simone that's not
healthy that's not out there with two
[ __ ] morons and then he sees run is
easy so everybody's 20 years ahead of
him you know he has a girlfriend who's
maybe his age and I told him a thousand
times to go to a simple jiu-jitsu school
you know I see that where I go our
burner cream is five or six guys they're
in their 20s they do everything together
they love each other they drink they
they they go to parties they you know I
am B them I don't have the time so I the
only four [ __ ] three years Lee you
can't keep hanging out with me and
Simone and your wife you have to get out
of that serger it does not have to be
jujitsu but somebody'll jump down so I'm
in social absolutely you know when you
go to 24-hour Fitness you don't talk to
nobody in North Hollywood I don't know
if you volunteer soup kitchen or if you
[ __ ] get here like a not even a big
brother thing but just join a club of
some kind and then like a trivia night
any anything that a softball league it's
just like you will make friends that way
and one else has a job and office to go
through and it's like 30 other people in
the office and you make your best five
friends you like they're the most and
you know that's
however you've mesh with but then you
get stuff in life that we have and you
don't see anybody you don't meet new
people and it becomes kind of weird so
that's one of that ideas just go out and
like meet people from helping children
position where you will become the Inc
be you know I mean I had to tell your
brother I would not have to listen to
you and lead in the podcast the other
night I've had bouts with it last night
I went to the comics tried to spots I
was at the Comedy Store from 10:00 to
9:00 and I left the 22:12 I read you
know I had a great [ __ ] time
yeah we're on wine and talking to you
know Dean Delray and Kevin Nealon three
months ago did you talk to me I didn't
want to go to [ __ ] Comedy Store right
and those are parts of we all suffer
from something you know I think it's
time to hire a hypnotherapist when I was
having brother my breathing and I would
go to and I gotta tell you some of those
10 sessions I felt a lot better just
because I had somebody to rap that was
neutral because like you said Ari we
have a thousand friends the [ __ ] we got
they're not gonna figure out they're
gonna brush it all
it's like Rogen didn't understand I
don't understand the question sometimes
remember I feel horrible because I call
Lee at 6:00 in the morning you know me
Ari and I'll tell them get out there
[ __ ] go get some Sun go for a walk
and now I feel bad because you said that
there's times that you see that but that
that seems like a [ __ ] hike up a
mountain to you just to go out there I
didn't get in or walk to the
refrigerator so I have to apologize
because I didn't know where I was coming
from but I mean for me I it wasn't I
appreciate that
wicked you were on me when I was 300
pounds to go work out and I don't know I
never really I haven't had like huge
it's always just been there so it's not
like sometimes it's worse sometimes it's
better but I haven't had like I'm not
getting out of bed for weeks at a time I
haven't been at that level so like when
I
started working out it was essentially
just because you kept asking and I hated
saying I wasn't doing it so then like I
I started doing and I like I would just
do it and I don't do it the issue is
like I they sticking with it is like I
would go out for a day and be in the Sun
I did it like two days last week but
then I get busy and I started thinking
oh I need I need to do this for this
person or I'm supposed to do this or and
then it goes away and then the
depression comes back so it's like a
part of it is I need to be better about
doing it every day doing whatever I do
for it every day how do you feel today
re today I feel honestly I stayed in bed
too long looking in the computer
answering emails and I didn't get up and
get you to sign now it's raining so I
kind of missed it so but but once I get
outside I'll feel better once I get out
among people I'll feel better I know by
now that's what happens
well yes generally we get hit up great
like where's your head at
just in general do you feel anything I
mean I feel great in general abaca sign
um yeah I'm having a good time my head
I'm okay now now in closing is there any
advice you could give somebody that's
going through I mean are we just had
[ __ ] one of the biggest musicians
just one night hang so yeah I just
[ __ ] hang himself okay what I mean I
can't stop listening to the guy for the
last since he hung himself and then two
weeks ago the other guy from the Lincoln
Park hangs himself you know there's
people that have this stupid theories I
listen as something that is not right
there yeah something was not right with
Cornell for him to do this I got to be
honest with you and what we do you know
what comics we could lose our minds the
same way our I will all gonna [ __ ]
die but I would hate to die in that
situation I mean nobody's here forever
but what would force you you know to
sell out a [ __ ] club have a great
show you have wife or kids at home your
money in the bank
Publishing he was in three different
bands and one night after a show and
[ __ ] Detroit of all places he hangs
himself dad yeah this [ __ ] out of just
jerking off but you want some be
illogical theta I was just taking off
all like the guy from INXS yeah and the
guy from na karoti does carrying yeah is
that what they're saying there yeah yeah
because it's like no note and also like
himself from a doorknob it's just like
weird why not a beam you know like well
not with people I play bridge at home
because what people how people don't
understand depression and what it looks
like people are successful you can never
get told Richard Cory I just looked it
up whenever Richard Cory went to went
downtown weed people on the pavement
looked at him he was a gentleman who
sold to crown clean favors and purely
slim it was always quietly irate and it
was always human way to hook but still
he fluttered pulses when he said good
morning hit glittered when he walked and
he was rich
yes Richard in a king and admirably
schooled in every grace and fine we
thought he was everything to make a
swish that we were in his place so on we
worked and waited for the light and went
without meat and cursed the bread and
Richard Cory 1.com summer night went
home and put a bullet through his head
you know things all what they see you
get some weird stuff with your head you
got it you got to figure it out not
about how are you doing or how good your
job is and how good your friends are
about something else so those are things
you should do right now
get some Sun every day try to take those
five positive things every day in the
shower yeah Steve Simone and he ends his
podcast doing that and when we first
started it was hard for me it was weird
yeah like I didn't know what I would
small things and he would pick really
big like really like I always felt like
my list wasn't as good as his but it
that has helped it's been a interesting
I don't know why he called studying here
yeah do those every day and then start
start call your insurance provider today
is true today and get yourself a
therapist and the one you talk to will
tell you if you need a different one
just get started it might be boring at
first but even with the city sag
insurance I got 10 free visits or you
know copay visits like 20 bucks a pop or
something first [ __ ] Obamacare I
didn't drop it all for everybody I'm
Plan B but you get two visits so like
use them like get in there now I start
make a call I figure out the phone well
I get someone who can help you like six
sticks looking at Bank because you want
to get back to a place that's happy yeah
absolutely
Thank You Ari I'm definitely gonna call
in it I don't know I don't know why I've
been so hesitant to try it and there's a
lot of reasons of stigma like I don't
need a guy who wants to go to the
therapist but everybody John everybody
goes fishing our leg it's not staying
over
we're also like I wanna be able do it
for myself that's all [ __ ] call
[ __ ] you know it's just like just
get it done I could none of that matters
they call the fire department you have a
fire yeah I gotta pull it out yourself
brother huh this has been as educational
as can be I the last two days after
listening to that podcast and seen the
comments and what's been going on I
didn't know this was this big of an
issue and if I've said something
negative in the podcast or any time I
apologized for everybody's going through
this my brother we'll talk tomorrow
I'm happy you called up and what content
you wanted tonight fish look at eating
fried [ __ ] you
where you gonna salmon patties burger in
the foyer
oh my god
well listen brother have a great time
I'm happy you shared with the church
family I'm sure they'll take care
whatever the [ __ ] they got to take care
of especially this little [ __ ] Jew
over here next to me but I love with my
heart I love you yeah it's just like you
have people to care about Sharon like
you can you can fix you can make
yourself feel better
hey let's pick up three steps as you
don't forget from as much as I've talked
about how I didn't feel like I had that
uh support in the past the past couple
days has been amazing there's been a lot
of people reaching out from people
listening to the podcast and comedians
and people that I've done work with so
it's been a that that's kind of nice if
I get I focus a lot on stuff that
happened in the past and I don't really
look at what's going on now so it's nice
when when I when you reach out and
people are going yeah but actually we're
here for you so it's been a very nice
couple days yeah only one other tip that
I got from a Buddhist monastery
somewhere in Myanmar Skype this Chinese
plane Buddhism Sunday and he said the
Buddha says that all suffering all human
suffering comes from living in the past
to the future and if you live in the
present you won't have that I understand
what that means he said okay he goes on
he goes look country view I was like
America it is ok there's book English
use like how many friends do you have I
was like how 60 to see 40 on the
complete set base 40 let's say 40 years
I'd not going out looking to me all
suffering comes living in the past the
future and he goes what country are you
how's it go all right like Myanmar is
that yeah this how many friends you have
like one yeah so some of the warring it
comes from like what am I gonna do with
my life or what have I done the past
it's like doesn't matter to here right
now wherever you are and you put your
friend Joey things are pretty good you
know yeah absolutely and stuff but it's
it's hard to do if you live in the
present it helps you a little to know I
think that would be my big goal yeah
that'd be my goal to talk to someone
that's that's
I think that's my biggest problem even
without depression even like you leaving
the depression aside so that's and
that's just not lead I'm talking for
everybody listen to this podcast
who's feeling a little weird man that's
it we've opened up a an animal here and
I'm happy that we did I love you buddy
all right let me to thank you for the
call thank you for opening up men yeah
talk to her all right
yeah interesting as [ __ ] I'm uh I know
in the five years I've been doing the
podcast I've never understood depression
so when we came up with this the other
night it blew me out of the [ __ ]
water I mean I basically didn't sleep
that night because I didn't see it I
always take pride at least noticing
something we're seeing things you know I
do notice you know now that we've all
put on the open when pain all that [ __ ]
affects it affects us in a lot of ways
you know later on like when I came out
here hide that that that fast weight
gain you know when I got out in 97 right
like a year later I had this weight gain
I kept getting letters from my ex-wife
telling me to sign my daughter's rights
over and the pain of that made me feed
the [ __ ] hole you know I mean pain it
all works a certain way you know I see
little things with you now that why we
have the procrastination issues you know
I gave you a sheet of paper Monday
yesterday you should got to gone there
and signed up for this you know you
always put things in front of the most
important things and you cannot do that
in your life and I've told you a
thousand times it's like you went to
Heinz nine the next day you can go cuz
you have to pick a business card you
don't need Business College at all at
all you gave away one business card
since that day right there sitting there
getting dust but you've always put those
things and you don't do it when it comes
to the work which is here so it has
nothing to do with me you know I was
doing projects or the people that
you go in the house and then I do the
project you did with them they're doing
something else and they complained you
don't do that you take it you do it to
yourself a hundred percent of the
consent you know I'll always put myself
last which is the weight gain which is
not exercising which is not going I
think I was a dentist for like five
years it just I don't know it's listen I
did all these same things and when I
went up to 418 pound it wasn't because I
was going to the gym every day it wasn't
because I was eating right it wasn't it
was because there was parts of me that I
didn't know where my life was going I
didn't give a [ __ ] I didn't give a [ __ ]
and then something will happen on the
way the dance I fell in love I realized
that the person I was with wasn't just
some [ __ ] check that I had been with
before this was a woman who actually
care about me and if something would
happen to me it would [ __ ] kill her
she's that type of person because she
was involved in it you know and right
those days I call you now say different
things he on the phone had been that
hurtful I'm just trying to [ __ ] get
you get the [ __ ] out of goddamn house
because this is a gift that nobody could
give you I would I wasn't born with when
I realized that the world didn't know me
nothing is when I put it into gear I
know I let it I say of all the things
that you have to follow what the [ __ ]
does this guy want to live doesn't this
guy want to do things it on 54 and I
know what was important to me and I know
where I wasted my time and nothing
bothers me more and the wasted time I
did in my life
nothing there's nothing that bothers me
do me a favor give these shoutouts why
like to go take a little peepee pooping
creativity hello everybody thank you so
much which one say thank you to everyone
who's a email to Twitter everyone it's
been a it's been an amazing couple days
mr. Lou Lingus Bob alingas thank you so
much bud King / deep double-oh-seven
mark non-smoking narc Coey Cory smelly
Brian Howard
couch e 1 1 2 1 slid Bell Jerry Brown
and Michael sesor Oni thank you so much
kooky spooky has been out there Agostino
D'Agostino has been out there Josh wolf
has been out to helping me feel Vaughn's
been very nice
just everybody I just want to say thank
you and and shout out to the church
family all right
he gave me a little shout out plus I
also need a big favor from you guys
tomorrow night tomorrow night is Olga
stirred and at a TBS tomorrow night I
guess that was on the show Greg Garcia
the show premieres what's the name of
the show look on and TBS on it's great
it's a August 3rd I believe it's 10:00
p.m. or 9:00 p.m. it's on TBS it's a
hysterical and the best part about it
every week it's going to be different
it's an amazing and amazing show please
go watch it please go watch it now I
want to talk to you about something
before we get the [ __ ] out of here and
you're going to figure out I'm a pretty
[ __ ] boring guy Leo tell you I'm as
boring as they come if you ever look at
my Facebook and Twitter feeds that
basically the same [ __ ] every day but
the thing that I put on there the most
and I want you people to notice it's a
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
I put that up to every day in my journal
when I wake up every morning that's the
first line if the first line in my
journal is Wednesday August 2nd 2017
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive God gave me another chance to live
waiting I write those dumb things every
day it's a beautiful day to be alive
because I'm telling myself I'm telling
myself from 6 to 10 I'm not a regular
person from 6 to 10 I'm trying to let me
know because for years I woke up saying
it was going to be a shitty day for 30
[ __ ] years I woke up saying it was
going to be a shitty [ __ ] day so the
last 15 years every time I wake up and I
say it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be
alive and I tell you I love telling
somebody on the street when I'm stoned
to the gills when I'm going to do
something they go good morning and I
look at them like oh it's a beautiful
gonna be alive and they just look at me
that is the dumbest sentence that could
ever come out of my mouth people but I
put that on Twitter every [ __ ] day
for a [ __ ] reason to remind me how
[ __ ] much of a beautiful day it is to
be alive you know I have a joking
onstage now listen guys as much dumb as
it sounds I don't smoke pot because I
want to be cool I'm gonna tell you
[ __ ] right now I never gave a
[ __ ] about none of that [ __ ] you either
like me or you didn't I smoke pot
because I really needed it when I get up
in the morning I'm just like you Lee my
first 10 steps
20 steps are scratching schedules
telling myself I'm gonna cancel the spot
at the store because I'm just gonna bomb
I'm gonna cancel this audition cuz I'm
not gonna get it you know what I'm gonna
talk to my wife about maybe moving out
because you're not getting yeah I get
all those thoughts I go in I drink
coffee and I get a blank piece of paper
I do this every day the last maybe 14
years do you want to talk about why my
life has changed absolutely because that
was the secret there's a book years ago
called the Warriors way or the artists
way and all these [ __ ] Gentiles went
crazy over it but it's like everything
else they read it they did the exercises
for two weeks then they moved on with
their life I've been doing that I got I
have notebooks upon notebooks on a box
of my closet from 1998 well I decided
one day instead of writing my comedy
sets out no more time I don't give a
[ __ ] about God I do comment every night
is to wake up in the morning and dump on
that paper there is not a thing that I
don't write out if I have a problem with
somebody when kappa rule
did the second podcast and people were
calling me up at my house and after the
things he was saying I didn't call him I
didn't take it to Twitter I went in a
notebook and I wrote the situation out
and the situation disappeared out of my
money for everything I'm hearing from RA
like it seems like you've figured out
ways to to make yourself better almost
again every day your job as a human
being is to be a little better than the
day before what does that mean that if
you woke up and get 700 [ __ ] pound
and you said enough of this [ __ ]
lifestyle today I'm going to walk three
steps and I'm going to clean my ass
myself tomorrow walk four steps ever
since I started living that lifestyle
and listen guys listen I can sit here
and tell you that I've been living this
lifestyle suppose maybe I was 40 I'm
gonna line nobody and tell you I
invented this but what happens when
you're 40
I let it'll go that far I was that
frustrating between the addiction the
criminology to [ __ ] eat bad and
there's a point where you disappoint Lee
with you reading that sick slice of
pizza and you know it's battery is a you
talked about wanting the dough get the
coke I know it's bad I think I just like
going I think maybe because I like
thinking about the food because yeah
once as soon as you start writing here
like this doesn't even take like even
when I was still going a fast food the
first fast food to go were Taco Bell
because I had I just had like three bad
I wasn't I would so I was flowing half
the food away even when I was stoned I
think like that's how I knew it was
terrible I guarantee that you start
talking to someone you take this
seriously yeah I guarantee you'll lose
80 pounds off the bat because this is
all connected yeah I think this is all
connected because you're telling me I
mean you do one thing twice and it's all
whether it's crepes whether it's
jiu-jitsu whether it's you know the
kettlebells you stucks long strong work
because they like you you like them and
you trusted them yeah I took yeah busted
then after that
you don't trust nobody you know that the
confrontation thing I was not saying
nothing bad no no I know it's a
completely true
jiu-jitsu karate judo there's a point in
all those things where they're gonna
make you go a little wider just so if
you ever on the street you know going to
shock right okay you don't go into shock
why take self-defense if you have to if
you don't know how to whether they shock
in your body that somebody no shock from
your mind when something happens if
something happens real fast and hear you
on the floor bleeding from your lip do
you does your head spin out or do you go
back to centralizing yourself in
breathing just to observe the situation
it's your breath tits out of control if
you control your breath you control the
situation okay I mean yeah I don't for I
don't know if I have a problem with
breath but maybe would help maybe
there's been working on that technique
would slow my brain down you know I know
this now we've had 20,000 people come in
here that specialize in different types
of things whether it's kettlebells and
you've looked into it but then your mind
hasn't let you take the step yeah so
maybe it's time that this is all
connected this is maybe something that's
connected it's good that you brought it
up and got it out of the goddamn way you
know I'm really [ __ ] proud of you you
know I had no idea of it so the first
person I tend to call was Ari because
Ari had gone through all this stuff I
heard bits and pieces I'm so happy I
think he spoke about it on his own
podcast what he had got to not in such
detail right yeah I mean it's a look
first of all thank you and then it's a
it's nice that's why I like because I
had a head hurt or we speak about it and
I've heard a lot of people speak Rossi I
feel like right now it's almost kind of
cool to have mental health issues in a
weird way like I went through a Blue
Mountain not as I want to say depression
but like after I spoke about I felt bad
almost I was like I don't know like I
haven't died this isn't diagnosed so I
felt I felt guilty about using the word
depression is it's like he said maybe
you that suffering from depression right
but there's got to be something that's
bothering you something deep right like
you said you keep thinking about your
childhood so I met listen I live in
nineteen [ __ ] eighty and I'm not
ashamed to say that when I'm not here
with you I'm not with my family or I'm
not writing calmly in my mind is when I
let idle hands my mind takes me back
into the eighties and all the [ __ ] I did
and how can I have done this and what
was the cause this and some things yeah
I put a cause to it but some things were
just because I was a piece of [ __ ]
we never get me wrong you know something
wrong with your mind you being a piece
of [ __ ] there's two different [ __ ]
thing right at Gap so the things I did
was because of need or hurt or pain some
of the things I did is I was a piece of
[ __ ] there's no two ways to [ __ ] look
at it so I that's where I live I mean
that's where my head is at best times I
go I'm getting out of it right it's
listening to you and oli made me realize
like there's obviously certain ways or
certain places that I feel comfortable
and maybe that's not good maybe maybe oh
maybe just because it feels safe doesn't
mean I have to go jump off of a cliff
but maybe I should join one of these
places that you can go and work all day
and everyone's working on normal small
business and there's like little tape
communal tables or who knows and there's
nothing like that you have to assume
that there's nothing like that
okay you have to come to these things
you have to keep yourself busy you have
to stay on it you know you don't
motivates me me money doesn't motivate
me my daughter doesn't motivate me me me
because there was so much wasted time in
my life the now I'm just playing [ __ ]
catch up man I'm just playing [ __ ]
catch up you know I would hate for any
of you 20 year olds or 30 year olds or
even 40 euros that listen to the [ __ ]
podcast to ever waste as much time as I
did doing drugs and thinking about
robbing people and thinking about
selling kilos is stupidity I wish I
would have taken that thought into
something positive
I'm very sorry it took me 30 [ __ ]
years for a positive thought to come in
my mind to make me start comedy and make
me stick with it you know I said here
[ __ ] amazed now with all the [ __ ] I
had going through I stuck with something
that bothered me Lee for years that you
stuck with it even when I was a [ __ ]
kids
my stepfather used to [ __ ] harass me
about this [ __ ] that I had done like I'd
I played the bass I played the drums I
sang in a band you know I went to judo I
went to karate I went to kung fu' I
played football I played [ __ ] tennis
I swam you know I tried everything I
invested money and I quit then guess
what happened then I quit [ __ ] high
school which I created a horrible
[ __ ] pattern once I quit high school
that was the [ __ ] pattern that my
mind was looking for yeah that's the
pattern that society wants you to have
when you just quit and then I just would
take jobs and quit jobs I was a plumber
I was a painter I was amazing I was no
electrician I was a roofer I was a
framer I was a carpenter's [ __ ]
helper I laid the linoleum that I laid
tile I was a cook I was a dishwasher I
was a [ __ ] sigh solve everything name
one thing I even sold the [ __ ] that you
put in [ __ ] your sanitary tub so your
yard don't blow up with [ __ ] and piss
what's those things those pellets that
you call I called everybody in this
country tried to sell one thing or
another at one time or another I was
always looking for something better
always looking for the grass to be green
always oh my god I sold me a nice old
medical packages I mean I sold it
[ __ ] all I delivered sandwiches I
delivered Chinese food you know guys I
sold [ __ ] the floor and they sold
pies but I would tell you I worked in a
tire store and then [ __ ] quit at one
o'clock somebody was saying the other
day that they got me all damaged on
came to the comedy show the other day
and he goes I'd never forget we were
kids
and they got you a job at a shirt
company and you said I'll be right back
you left an hour and I would I wouldn't
even wait till lunchtime I was a [ __ ]
loser I was a [ __ ] loser
and then with the thought economy came
into my mind because I quit everything
it took me what I told you 18 months to
go down and do comedy all around that
[ __ ] time it felt like 18 months and
then after I did it for two years I
still [ __ ] around like I'm a comedian
I just need to go onstage once a month I
never committed to [ __ ] guys do you
understand me you want to be a real
[ __ ] loser don't commit to nothing
don't commit to nothing you got to
commit to something because eventually
that one commitment value commit to two
things
now you commit to three things I got
divorced dawg I bailed that on every
[ __ ] situation that was ever thrown
at me do you think we like when I'm when
I'm coming there here is like not
everything is going to be great all the
time I don't know maybe maybe that's
what I'm searching for and just doesn't
exist nobody I didn't know what I was
searching for leave the [ __ ] times
right yeah give me the answer to that
all I know is that I quit everything
right I was a [ __ ] stucco I installed
the normal of what society did you know
that there was a job I took [ __ ]
building scaffolds I quit on lunchtime -
I used to install railroad ties I quit
that - guys I [ __ ] was a pathetic
loser
but for some reason for some [ __ ]
reason at the age of 28 I got into
comedy and I didn't commit I didn't
commit to comedy to the age of 31 and
that's when I told myself I said either
I do this if I quit there's no more jobs
it's taking a bus back to New York City
get an ounce of coke and going into
business either until I'm dead I'm
busted I'm in jail or I kill myself with
cocaine that was the plan
this was not supposed to work but this
was the last thing I had and I had a
commit to it that's not funny did he
almost now want it to work like oh
please why would I why would you why
would somebody who's a quitter and
everything want something the water
why would somebody who quit everything
in their [ __ ] life
want something to work at first I did it
and then when I started doing it I know
I don't know hey guys something just
made me I understood what you had to do
but even at that point there was no I
didn't see any future at it all I was
looking at was a little less killable
time if we could kill some time we'll be
okay and it's fine you have your days
free and you just ended up working at
and liking it like it just sort of
happened I was a comment I knew that you
know I mean I'm trying to get my
passport that I call the lawyer he calls
back now no way Jose what's this warrant
in Idaho Holly libel warrant in Seattle
I want a [ __ ] Idaho because I stole a
tent and when I got into a fistfight you
know it never ended and even when I got
into the County and I knew the
commitment that calmly needed I was
still [ __ ] around but it didn't dawn
on me to like mid 95 you know what I
dawned on me that I was in love with
Tommy when when you realize that I was
actually getting better at it
once I was getting two or three laughs
I'm like wait a second I'm on to
something
were you working on it or were you just
going up there at that time I was I
would read you Junie Carter's work book
and I would write what she'd do and then
I go up there and I I was just learning
by doing you know I would watch as much
stand-up as I could the Great's Lennie
George Carlin [ __ ] Richard Pryor and
then I look at who's ever was hot in
those days and I would try to find the
fusion and that was wrong
you know it was all uh listen when you
get right now I'm in love would you
judge
you know why because it's like comedy
when I first started I'm so bad at it
cuz I gotta get good at it eventually
and I will once the body movements start
more and everything and I will it's just
the way life is
you don't saying but it also goes to the
commitment I put into it it's a
commitment I put into it
you know right now I'm very fortunate
I'm 54 but I'm living a certain
lifestyle I'm going to bed early
drinking water with all my meals you
know I never live like this before
because you have a reason to live
darling and you have a great reason oh
yeah oh your mother to give your father
and you have a sweet girl that would
crush or something happen to you you got
a heart attack but you got sick so this
is these all the things you know I
stopped doing coke yeah it was the cat
and the whole thing my wife is a lot of
[ __ ] things but she's a sweetheart
and I know how she still cries over
Fidel
oh you bring up her down she'll turn
around you won't see it but she'll cry a
little bit you can't bring up Freddie
around these are cats that I can't
imagine how to find the knee on the
floor with a mirror the razor blade the
follow me right doing coke I can't I
can't I could never do that to her it
was look when you're talking about when
you realize that about your wife like
you said like no it wasn't like another
girl you just had Texas from me I don't
have like I never really went out and
did like the hooking up phase but I also
never really had girls care about
medical who cheated on me and then I
just wouldn't have like long
relationships so yeah it's uh it kind of
freaked me out a little bit is that she
is so nice and I'm not saying guys if
you need a girlfriend to be happy could
be a [ __ ] cat yeah I'll be a bird it
could be a dog it could be an aunt
listening this I'm happiness out there
for you oh my night listen this whole
suicide thing and [ __ ] Lee has gotten
a little worked up here maybe a little
bit more they should but it made me
realize the problems that I have the
shortcomings I have like I told you what
we saw wasn't going to good myself I'm
never doing too [ __ ] good
you know I'm never doing too good
because I came from a [ __ ] foundation
that nothing good supposed to happen the
guys like me so when something does good
happen I'm walking around looking at
buildings because I want to see the
first one to fall on my [ __ ] head who
told you good things don't happen in
guys like you the same things that tell
you you know good enough the same thing
so thin tunnel sure it is sure it is you
know it's funny one time when The
Sopranos Tony Soprano master is a
psychologist so what the [ __ ] are we
doing here what you mean to tell me is
that everything goes back to your mother
everything goes back to that childhood
yeah everything goes back to that
childhood I sit here and I make the
quotes I have because I've analyzed that
childhood 200 times from zero to 10 and
I've analyzed my life 200 times from 10
to 20 you know probably was a time I was
going through some heavy [ __ ] and I'll
talk about him right now just so you
know the night my mother died she was
yelling for me I mean to come down I
told us because she wanted me to eat and
I didn't come down at but you don't want
one night a week later when I was
smoking pot I realized she was yelling
for me because she was getting a heart
attack and I was too lazy to [ __ ] go
down there
that's a heavy [ __ ] thing to live
with on your mind but it's not what I
did I didn't use that as I think I've
never even spoken about that is
something to define me I put it together
that when God wants you God want you
what could I had done for her Ryan
you're what ten years old nine years old
I was I was 15 15 you know it doesn't
really [ __ ] matter but you know I
could have let that stigmatize me for
[ __ ] life which I did which I did
yeah which I did in many ways okay I did
I made little adjustments when people
contact me I'll try to contact them back
I don't know what position they're in
you know little things like that you
know you don't know it was another
problem I had two or three years after
my mother died I had this doubt that I'm
gonna party with me
we got an eight ball of coke we got
friends here I'm having a little bit too
much of a good time for somebody whose
mother just died like maybe I just love
my mother or not like everybody else
loves their mother I went through that
crazily yeah what that was a year of
addiction and snortin and tears and fall
in the mornings and semen man on fire
when he hits drunk yes he would get all
[ __ ] and talk to himself and that's
what I would do that's what I would do
talk to myself and clean your gun and
that's what I did
that's just rapidity I used to do that
when the 18 months I lived it I didn't
love her enough you know what type of
guilt that is to put on a 17-year old 18
year old mine and to me it's amazing
that you made it sound sounds like
depressions amazing that you need down
yeah that's why do all these things
that's why I tell you [ __ ] on
Sundays it's going to be a great week
that's why I tell you [ __ ] that
don't worry about what happened last
week no matter just make sure the lab in
this week whatever that happened last
week
just don't make sure don't happen this
week just make sure it doesn't happen
this week and there's little precautions
you can take to always raise your
percentages to make your life a lot
better and you know what I don't know
what they are you know what the [ __ ]
they are nobody really wants to face the
music because I didn't you know all
these little things that happen to me
from the age of 44 getting the Longest
Yard and MADtv and all this [ __ ] was
little things that took over time first
of all I hadn't talked myself into being
good enough to go to an audition hey
you're gonna know that you deserved it
yeah like haha so we've all had our
[ __ ] struggles it's just how we've
handled them and I tell you I really
like that Ari thing about the five
things for the good in your life every
day in the shower because that's the
joke
that I get up in the morning I hate
myself and you a cup of coffee
I smoke Dubonnet I eat a piece of
nicotine gum and mixed you know I'm
[ __ ] Elvis in the shower that's the
truth when I get in the shower but um I
get in the shower why do you think I'm
getting this out because I'm ready to go
kill a [ __ ]
yeah and that's I'd wait to shower
though after the gym probably usually so
maybe I should change my neighbor with a
lot of things are what in my mind I'm
ready to go stab a [ __ ] okay
yeah I think obviously I think talking
to someone would help but maybe they'd
be able to show me some of these things
that would help on top of it now I know
in a week I'm a shoe but the Jew in you
is not going to make you pay on your
name out to go talk to somebody
oh you read you got to go pay Paul his
mother lunch and talk in Spanish and try
to mingle it up but Lee you have to do
these things
oh yeah mom 100% it's about you meant to
have it's about your future because it's
like pennsville if you don't play this
now you don't have to pay for this later
yeah I'm seeing that I wish I had like
my mom like what ten years ago maybe
that you wanted me to go so now I'm
watching maybe added so yeah I think
you're absolutely right
that I shouldn't like I said like I
already said you over here stuff with
seventy-five-year-old Diaz and Steve
Simone is no [ __ ] battle of
enthusiasm he has is but [ __ ] days
too you have to get a set different you
know you have to go somewhere else
beside Paulo and tell this [ __ ] job
these guys crazy you made me 2,000
milligrams less welcome we can play
right in us it's it's really weird you
have to go somewhere and I've seen this
and I've been telling you for a [ __ ]
year
Zack always asked about him and Marco
and then and then
Wakefield Josiah Wakefield over at our
Berto kraines
it makes me jealous I'm not twenty-nine
a young kid they do stupid things they
go to movies together and they get a few
beers they go to some stupid bar down
the corner after you Jitsu right and
they goof on each other
do I miss that [ __ ] yeah am i lonely at
times
[ __ ] yeah
I'm lonely at times like a [ __ ]
but this is all the things that we have
to learn to deal with on our own without
the food right without the drugs without
the cocaine these are the things like
this you know so I'm just happy that you
came clean with this I think thank you
for the last guy this in the last couple
days it's a feel nice it like almost
feel like I've started a little bit I'll
call today
I'll find out today what I get what I
have you know I don't ever want this
listen man I had situations for this
podcast I always knew what I wanted this
podcast to be I always wanted this
podcast to be for me to explain things
to you guys by showing you the mistakes
I made in my life that that was the
number one thing about this podcast to
show you that all these comedians and
all these celebrities that you [ __ ]
morons look up to
bro that pieces of [ __ ] and they got
bigger problems they knew they just
persevered you know they just steamroll
through all of them half of it like Hari
said half these actors are in [ __ ]
therapy and genocide
why do they join Scientologists they're
[ __ ] crazy they're [ __ ] crazy me I
figure out a natural balance life is a
balance life is a nice little [ __ ]
balance you do a little bit of this you
do a little bit of that you do a little
bit of this you do a little bit of that
you spend time with this guy you spend
time with this guy when you want to work
out you hang out with this guy when you
want to do drugs hang out with this guy
when you look at you dicks up ya know it
did but you know it's just so many
different done like I said I'm just we
all deal with something yeah I know that
there's prevention hotline numbers out
there I'm sorry I'm busy this morning
and part of that was to you know I had
meetings but I always know I want to do
this podcast and we had a short time
when I read because I was going on
concert tonight we didn't really know so
I have it if you want it what's the
number 1-800 to seventy three eight two
five five and then I'm also looking they
actually have an online chat so if you
want to do that one two times you have
all the
I'm happy that we could talk about this
subject I wanted to after Monday we had
a different guest lines up but we pushed
him back just because I want to already
call in and talk about the situation he
had gone through whatnot did you do the
[ __ ] shout out to these savages
absolutely oh [ __ ] my man Bobby Lingus
but King / deep 0:07
mark non-smoking mark whatever Corey
smelly Brian Howard kouchi 1121
sleazeball Gerry Dee Brown and Michael
Cesare Lee I love you [ __ ]
and don't forget this Saturday night
myself
Eddie Bravo Eddie Bravo was doing ten
minutes and the rest of the show is
working out with uncle Joey at the ice
house 7:30 Saturday night then the
following week oh [ __ ] we're back up in
SFO the punchline [ __ ] from the 10th
to the 12th that's what I'll be doing
well you got planned for the weekend you
sexy [ __ ] savage you what do I have
planned you know what uh I don't think I
have much but I'm gonna I'm gonna try to
do something different something that I
haven't done before I don't know what it
is maybe go I think I think I like one
of them one of those clubs or something
look for something what kind of Club
I don't know the sex club that'd be
great - maybe a sex guy I was even
thinking I got some people who reached
out about those those are tech people
that I saw in Vegas okay and they have a
podcast so I was thinking about maybe
going and seeing maybe they have like a
a coding Club or who knows just I'd
learn a new skill and then I said good
guys some guy asked you we got to know
that Harris yeah there for two hours
last night going what [ __ ] note and
when I saw you answer him back what
happened to hammers he was a it was the
guy who I met who worked at the casino
okay and he worked in the the gambling
Department late at night and he just
came over and introduced himself I was
playing PI gal and the dealer the dealer
was taking me through it like I love
that's why I like I'm always gonna talk
him at tables and we steal her it was
like a gay guy it was midnight they were
like four
for other people the table and we were
just having a blast they came over and
he said I love the show thank you so
much and them we just came Paul and I
went back the next night and he was
there again and he gave me a note just
to say this too so he could keep in
touch and it must have fallen out of my
pocket at the table so I wanted him to
reach out he did and yeah was a there
was a bunch of people in Vegas what a
server at a restaurant and that's that's
the the last couple days has shown me
but I've known it since we started
everywhere I go that I ever meet anybody
from this or it's just a it's always
very positive so even if I feel like may
I may be in my own like personal life I
don't have people who I don't think I
people there's people out there and then
maybe for Pete for other listeners of
the show because I got Jack said brother
I'm y'all looking for fans right we're
going people come up to me and asking
for a [ __ ] autograph right I want
everybody will listen to this podcast no
were like a family man and you ask guys
like Bobby and Krystal ask guys like
[ __ ] talking let ask them ask [ __ ]
Australian warrior ouki spooky every
Aaliyah
every year we get a different [ __ ]
family member Cleo and somewhere another
man this is going to be this is great
because we each which tongue and groove
you know what tongue and groove is know
we each need a little bus a hat you know
I remember I got a note from Bobby
Crystal Bob will lend us his [ __ ]
family our IP is bad he was family can't
you know we I want everybody know
whether you're in Ireland and [ __ ]
China and Hong Kong you're part of the
[ __ ] Church family man and
[ __ ] up [ __ ] happens
as berg when his kid was sick and he had
the church shirt on and he went to my
hospital and the guy you know we know
this and some people go away because
they don't believe this
they don't believe we're family listen
man I had no blood in this world except
an uncle and a sister in Cuba and those
guys I grew up with 54 years later tell
my family you don't have to be blood to
be [ __ ] family
it's feeling from one another that's it
that's fan that's when you know
somebody's family it's a bigger
difference than a friend you know
there's been things years ago the kids
house broke that when we tweeted this
[ __ ] GoFundMe and it should happen
you know little things like this and
we're a family we try when talking man
got sick right you know he had the
GoFundMe page we all [ __ ] kicked him
nobody because nobody's a millionaire
here but then everything helps we're a
family guys so when I found out that
this existed and I saw how many [ __ ]
people reached out to Lee and said it
talked about their own insecurities I
said suck it we got to get all ready to
call in and break it down a little more
and see if some of all this mean the
[ __ ] middle here so thank you very
much listening to the podcast and never
ever ever forget this with the church
family [ __ ] balls out balls out man
be proud who gives a [ __ ] we say what we
say and we mean what we mean and that's
just the way the [ __ ] show ends
[ __ ] anyway real quick let me do
some [ __ ] heads and we'll get you the
[ __ ] out of here number one on it
baddest mother [ __ ] supplements out
there I love to death you understand me
love them to death from the shroom Tech
to the hem force protein you want to
know what the [ __ ] I used that's what it
is I love the hem foot protein for
breakfast I get a little alpha brain in
that when I write comedy just to get all
the [ __ ] cylinders going and remember
if the Alpha brain don't work for you
it's 100% money-back guarantee no
questions asked we didn't want to bottle
back that's their flagship product if
that's how they treat their flagship
product how the [ __ ] are they going to
take care you as a customer you
understand me all their products are
tremendous go to honor combat metal
press in church BAM
and get 10% off with the package
delivered right to your house it's that
type of party okay reputation I go to
you gentlemen fat [ __ ] I have these
people give me these [ __ ] jujitsu
compression under way as they suck dick
because the whole class I got to pull
them down and I got to pick them up and
I tell you what
you know what works for me for jiu-jitsu
I'll tell you right now Mayim these
number one they [ __ ] snuck onto your
skin so the GEEP pants snug on to them
and your deep pants don't go anywhere
number two you go to jiu-jitsu you're
sweating it
you're [ __ ] muffler sweating up a
storm not with me I'm these me on these
has that modal it controls the threat it
keeps it nice and [ __ ] dry in there
and this is the reason why I wear me on
these whatever the [ __ ] I work out or
whatever the hell I'm doing cuz of
control comfort and it keeps everything
the smelly boot you know I'm telling the
control like I said me on these are the
softest most comfortable underwear
you'll have a wet period and summer is
the perfect time to upgrade your on the
way draw because everybody's out there
thinking about looking good and feeling
good and the undies are the ultimate
feel good on these every pair me undies
is sustainably sourced and made from
micro mode or of fabric that's three
times ruffling car do you think I'm
talking about it if you used to buy and
boring underwear me and these won't
change that because me undies comes in
all kinds of colors and patterns and
they release new limited-edition
patterns each month that always sell out
sometimes I wear a white key and I wear
polka dot underwear people laugh at me
but who the hell cares my balls are
fresh this much patterns were designed
by the legendary eighties clothing brand
cross coolers with names that live up to
that bold design and bright colors
increase the peace your dig and the OG
you got to see them for yourself and
right now you'll save 20% off your first
pair and you'll receive free shipping
only at me on these cars last Joey
there's a reason me undies are sold over
5 million pairs to date you know why
because you'll feel it when you put them
on and if you don't love the first pair
listen they're free bing-bang-boom
that's the way we do it now today get
20% off your first pair plus free
shipping at me undies comm slash Joey
again that's me undies
I'm slash Joey 20 percent off your first
pair plus free shipping you can't lose
listen you have the best melon balls
around you got to be comfortable it's
gonna look great with pants on you're
going to tweet me a year from now Joey I
love my me on these again beyond these
dot-com slash showing and that's it and
that's that brother what's the matter
with you nothing nothing crying already
anyway I love your mother [ __ ] if I
don't see you sadly at the ice house
I'll see you the following week at San
Francisco let's blast a whole lot of
love for the family brother thank you
for listening to the church guys and
thank you for participating in our lives
and thank you for supporting the state
black have a great weekend